This video is the one of the, maybe of the year. Okay.
This Papa John's interview
world on w WDRB news, uh,
Timothy Burke on Twitter, uh, tweeted a book,
a clip of a bunch of these things. This guy, Papa John's got,
he was on a call and an internal call that I guess leaked.
And he said the N word a bunch of times, which is so weird.
My whole thing is even now in 2019, even if you are racist,
it's so weird to not know,
not to do those things. Even if you are racist,
it's so weird to know, like blackface a Halloween to just be like, yeah,
I know I'm going to get in trouble, but it.
Or to say the N word at a meeting, knowing it's bad,
this guy's in his fifties, maybe even 60 knows it's bad.
And to still be like, yeah, but I'm still racist.
Got to say the N-word got to just leak it out. Somehow in this, in this meeting,
I haven't said it yet today. I haven't heard the phone call,
but that it's just incredible. Is it out there? I wonder if you could find it.
I doubt it's out there. What made it somewhere and the dark web, but anyway,
he got fired or, you know,
he stepped down or whatever the hell happened from Papa John's and now there's a
new guy running Papa John's pizza, obviously. And this guy
who used to run the,
the creator or the owner of Papa John's whatever CEO of Papa John's,
what's his name? Uh, I don't know what his name is,
but anyway, the founder of
John Shatner, Schneider, John Schneider
use the N word on a conference call in may God.
He looks like a guy that would use the N word too. You know? So anyway,
this is a, uh, a clip, a bunch of clips from the interview.
Now that came out today, WDRB WDRB news,
WDRB news, about a day, they had to sit down and by the way,
the guy who was interviewing is black,
which is like so interesting because he's got, he was disgraced.
He said, Edward, anyway, here we go.
This is some of the stuff he's had 40 pizzas in the last 30 days. First of all,
gonna die. Okay. First of all,
gunna die. That means, dude,
that means he's had a whole pizza for a lunch or
dinner. One of the days out of the 30 days in the month.
And then also 10 more of those days,
he ate a whole pizza for another meal,
a fat made of dough.
Just so much how's this guy, not 900 pounds.
Look.
I've had over 40 pizzas in the last 30 days.
Living currently in Mark Shapiro should be in jail.
Okay. Who's that? That's the new guy.
Mark Shapiro should be in jail. Who's Mark Shapiro.
We got to look that up as you look that up.
Keep going. I've had over 40 pizzas in the last 30 days currently.
And Mark Shapiro should be in jail. He has no pizza experience.
He's never been in the pizza category.
Okay. So has no pizza experience,
I guess he has no experience making pizza, I guess. Uh,
okay. Fine. Never been pizza.
You can tell he doesn't give interviews a lot. You know,
never been in the pizza.
[inaudible] it's like the, what?
Supersize me documentary board members, uh,
Livia currently and Mark Shapiro. Okay. So Papa John's new leaders,
including Steve Richie who replaced him as CEO and the board members,
Olivia and Marsha, where they should be in jail, dude. Oh.
Cause they stole the company away and now they've destroyed the company. Ah,
man, I man, I ain't going to jail at all. In any case, any way,
shape or form over pizza. What are you in for a,
I killed, if you guys, what are you in here for looked? If your kids,
what are you in here for food
eaten 40 pieces in 30 days. That's what I'm in there for.
Why does he sound like he should be in a, in um,
with the lights out in just the silhouette talking in front of a,
like a curtain in a, in a holiday Inn, like a
hit over 40 piece. Sounds like an informant. That's trying to,
trying to remain anonymous, but he's.
I've had over 40 pizzas in the last 30 days living currently and Mark
Shapiro should be in jail. He has no pizza experience.
He's never been in the pizza category. I would just say,
stay tuned. Their record will come.
The record will be straight. Why not set the record.
Dude? The day of reckoning for what dude?
You said the N word and you can't say the N word at a
business meeting. If you're that racist,
just go home and let it out to nobody at night,
just get home and just be like, okay,
you know, he's just sitting there eating 40 pizzas in 30 days, just like
forking, more marks or purer,
just eating food. That's why it sounds like that.
Cause he had 40 pizzas in 30 days dead.
They tune their.
Racking. So drunk.
The record will be straight. Why not set the record straight down? I mean,
what is it about the record? That's not stated.
What does he have up his Papa John's sleeve. What does this.
Guy, what does this.
Guy know that we don't know? You know,
stay tuned next month. [inaudible] that? That's what it is.
That's the day of reckoning. I'm going to [inaudible] that.
You're not even going to understand how many pizzas.
How about the fact too? This is the best part that Papa he.
Why is he wearing the without curly?
Mark Shapiro should be in jail. He has no pizza experience.
The Papa. John, he's still wearing a shirt that looks like a Papa John's shirt.
Guy wear blue. Hey guy wear a gray.
Had over 40 pizzas in the last 30 days. Dude.
I've had over 40 pizzas in the last 30 days.
I've had over 40 pizzas in the last 30 days, dude,
there was one that was really funny here. Over 40 pizzas.
This made me laugh for 40 pizzas, Timothy Burke, same guy. He put it.
I've had over 40 pizzas in the last 30 days.
I've heard over 40 pizzas in the last 30 days.
[inaudible]
who has had.
Over 40 pizzas period.
Dude.
I've had over 40 pizzas in the last 17 years.
Not even that, even that
if you've had over 40 pizzas.
In 10 years, you're a fat pig.
If you have had over 40 pizzas in the last 10 years,
if you've had over 40 pizzas in the last 10
years, you're a pig. It's like.
The, the guys on the QVC.
We have got 40 pizzas and
we don't have them in the last 10 years.
We don't have the last 40 pizzas in the
last five years. We don't have, can we go lower?
last three and a half years. We don't have, can we go lower? Let me check.
Hold on. Let me check and make sure we can go lower.
We don't have 40 pizzas
in the last one year. We don't have the last.
We don't have 40 pieces in the last year we ate,
we ate 40 pizzas.
We don't eat 40 pizzas in the last six months.
Can you believe that we don't eat?
We don't eat 40 pizzas in the last six months, we donate 40 pizzas.
In the last
four months.
Why don't need over 40 pizzas in the last
two months.
Okay.
For a limited time only right now
for a limited time only.
Now I've hit over 40 pizzas in the last 30 days.
For a limited time,
only 40 pizzas over 40 pizzas
in the last 30 days call. Now
we've got to look at these beautiful pizzas. We've got pepperoni.
We've got cheese, we've got pepperoni. We've got sausage.
We've got meat. Lovely. But I want to get a bit of meat levers.
We have got veggie pizzas.
You could have onions on them. You can have it on he's. We have margarita pizza.
We have barbecue chicken pizza.
For some reason we have Hawaiian pizzas,
even though pineapple doesn't belong on pizza. And everybody knows that
we've already voted pizzas in 30 days.
Also who's counting. Dude.
Imagine Eaton.
Imagine getting to your seventh pizza and being like seven dude.
My favorite thread though,
under this was cause the guy looks really shiny and he and somebody right?
Writes. Why is he so wet? And then somebody under the under it writes,
he's had 40 beaches and less
that make you wet. I'm going to hard that hard at it.
Then somebody wrote, there are two kinds of people. One in the pizza category,
two criminals. Oh.
Oh God. That. That's a meme for the ages bro.
Somebody wrote it, made it whatever. ESPN 40 for 30 big Papa,
ESPN films. 40 for 30. That's funny. Oh this guy.
I love out of touch people. It's so funny.
Why does he sound like that?
Why does he sound like that? Oh man.
I wish there was audio of him saying the N word.
That would be so funny and bad and weird.
That's from a guy who eats 40 pizzas though, bro. I don't know.
Anyway. Oh. That makes me laugh. So I was in Florida.
I actually ate a whole pizza in Florida. I won't build some less 30 days.
I ate one pizza. I felt like trash.
I actually ate one pizza. One night,
a big one.
And then the next night there was nothing to eat in Melbourne and we ordered a
Papa John's dude, I just remembered this. We ordered Papa John's we got
[inaudible] and I ate my chews.
And then, um,
and then Mike and Zack got one
and I never, I didn't get a cheese pizza. I got veggie pizza.
Cause I'm trying to be healthy. It's hilarious. And uh, they got Hawaiian pizza
and that's gross, dude. I, I,
pineapple is a amazing, huh?
Pineapple is so good. You know,
it really is just an, a, a flavor explosion in your mouth.
If you don't like pineapple, I get it. But if you like pineapple,
I super get it. You understand what I'm saying? Put it this way.
If there was ever going to be a fruit in spiked armor,
it would be pineapple because that's the one that tastes jamming.
You understand? That's the one that tastes like
[inaudible] that's the fruit. That's the bang and hot new hotness fruit dude.
If any fruit was going to be covered in spiked armor,
it would be a fruit that tastes like that. If it was an Apple, you'd be like,
it's not worth it. Dude. Apple is a great, but they're as good as their skin.
You understand pineapple? I used to have this joke where I was like,
Hey pineapple, why are you in spiked armor? What's in there.
$40. Stupid joke. Funny enough.
Uh, but what's in there 40 grand. I don't remember what the thing was.
It was stupid, but why is it so spiky? You know, like what was the deal?
This whole evolution of pineapple is crazy, man.
You know what should be in a armor is a peak put. So
that's so good. Pizza is so good. And I can't stand a hookers.
Keep talking about it on Instagram, but it is dude
Peter. So bang. And every time you take a bite of pizza, it's like this.
[Inaudible].